本能が悪異性が善と言われるとええと思う
わな理科系はどうしてかと言うと理性の
正体を大体みんな知っとるじゃん本のの
正体も知っとるじゃんところがリベラルは
自分たちが生前説っていうじゃん性前説の
性の意味を知らんのやあれは助教に
乗っとる言葉だから受okayを否定する
連中は生前説の意味はわからんよ生前説は
と言うと生まれながら人間は全であると
それでおしまいじゃそうじゃなしに
ヨーロッパの精神論の1番間違えとんのは
ね生まれながらに理性があるっていうとこ
ない理性は作るもの授okay見てみ仏教
見てみ大和魂もそうやどうやって正しい
理性を作るかというのが3つのテーマだ
それなのにヨーロッパ流のアメリカ流の
精神論でいけば理性作る必要ないやん
生まれた時からもうある世界人権宣言の
全部に呼んでこらんそう書いてあるから
そこが嘘なんだ理性の正体は知らん理性は
善であるなんていうバカなことが起こって
くるんやそうじゃなしに仏教を読んでら
理性は悪であるって書いてあるよ半神教
読んだらそう書いてあるやろ授業を読んで
もそう書いてあるだから人間は間違った
理性これが悪やね間違った理性を作るどう
やってそれを直すのかと
いうその直し方は授業は学習だ学びて時に
これを習う習うは行動だよ習うを学習する
と言うと普通勉強じゃんそうじゃない習う
は行動なんだ教わったこと正しいことを
教わるそれを実行する実行するとその精神
が身につくんだそうやって正しいこと
ずっとやっていけばそのうちに精神が理性
が全部正しくなるというのが受okay
ただし時間かかるよねだからこしだって
完全にその状態になるのは810歳になっ
た時やその間ずっと努力し続けよというの
が受業ね仏教はね手っ取りばやんやいい
方法があって
ねお釈迦様が最初は苦行をするわけね肉体
的な靴から悟ろうとするわけだあれは精神
は崇高なもの肉体は邪悪なものという哲学
やねだから肉体をずっと死に向かわせる
わけ死ぬ寸前に精神の方が勝つ必ずだから
精神が正しくなるこれが苦行の意味やねな
こんな嘘やからいくら肉体をいじめたって
精神は良くならない高くならない正しく
ならないでそれが分かったもんでお釈迦様
は森から出てきて釘やめたんや苦をやめて
まず栄養を取って体を元に戻してね座禅を
組んで瞑想をして何日間で下達したんだだ
から受業より仏教の方ががはかに能率的
早いだから今の防寒っていうのはみんな
下達しとるはずなんやけどどうもしてない
よねやり方が間違っとるんじゃないか
ね刑務所におる時に座禅クラブに入って
なかなか入れてくれんのややっと入って
最初の日に座禅しとったら指導する坊さが
来てなんかこうおちょくっていくんよね
お前座れるのかと座はずっと以前やった
ことあるからできると思いますただし何を
目的としてで座禅したらいいんですか言
目的のない行動なんてないもんねそしたら
ねその坊さんが目的を持った座りなど小さ
いってつったやそれであこいつ分かって
ないんだと思って目的持って何でも行動せ
ねよねこれが人間なんだからだから進歩
するんやからねで坊さんの悪口言ったんや
いつものように分かってないやらえと首に
なってやっぱり分かってなかったんだ症状
座禅を組むのは大体症状っていうやろ精神
を統一してと胸無双になる何のために無念
無双になるの無念無双ということは理性を
殺すということだ理性を殺したらなんかの
問題を本能で解けるじゃ
ない問題が来るあるいは今日1日をずっと
こう振り返ってみる無念無双で振り返って
みるんやねそうするとチクっと来るんや
あれと思うとこが来るそこは精神が間違っ
とったとこないただそれに気がつけばええ
のそうすると本能が勝手に直してくれる
正しいのはこっちと言ってくれるからね
結局肉体だけじゃなしに精神だって
ホメオスタシスがあるんだ正常化正常な
状態に戻ろうとするだから悪いとこに気が
ついてそこに集中してると正しく治っ
ちゃうんよねこれが少年のやり方な集中力
がいるね理性を殺すというその家庭がいる
んや理性を殺すのは症状でえんだ打電を
組んで胸無双になればいいそれが仏教の
やり方よだから意外と簡単にいろんな問題
がトントントントン自分でとんでも本能が
勝手に直してくれるから最終的に善に
なれるわ正しく
なれるでそれに比べて仏教でも授業でも
非常に科学的に精神を解明しとるよね結局
精神の進歩のさせ方という方法論を
作り上げとるんだ欧米流の精神論はそんな
もん全然ないよ大体進歩することは悪い
ことないどうしてだと思う神様が人間を
作ったからうん想像論だからないだから神
様は人間を作っただけじゃなしに彼の一生
まで決めとるんやそれが神の意思なんや
進歩したらその神の意思を逸脱することに
なるじゃん神をも恐れの行為ないそういう
宗教的理由で進歩を否定するにだけど
キリスト教徒ものすごい進歩するじゃん
科学でもスポーツでもだからキリスト教徒
がそんなもん信用してないあるいは最後の
審判の時に地獄に落とされてもええ今勝つ
方がええ今進歩した方がええ日本は信用し
とんのかキリスト教なんか誰も信じてない
よねそれなのにあのバカのリベラルそんな
ことを要求するんやねえっとね私の言う
ことは正しいことばっかりだだから今から
まだ続くからえー正しい
人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを送り
たけれ
ばチャンネル登録してずっと聞いてくれ